la celebración del día nacional del 14
de julio en francia no solamente es
dedicado internamente a la búsqueda de
la unión de la nación a una fiesta
nacional pero también al mandar mensajes
y hoy en día y lo dijeron perfectamente
a través de este desfile donde nueve
países de europa central y oriental
desfilaron pues allí se mandó mensajes
definitivamente en este contexto de
tensión a la frontera de europa y bien
dijo de raúl de guerra con sí con
consecuencias lo vimos con consecuencias
energéticas fue en el eje central de la
entrevista que yo después de este
desfile tradicional un momento clave de
14 julio el presidente de la república
fernando pues que ya vienen
en tiempos particulares para restringir
pues esas fuentes de energía que vienen
de rusia claro pascal también está pues
celebración del 14 de julio se da con
toda esta polémica que salpica
precisamente al presidente francés
emmanuel macro lo que estamos hablando
de la investigación de uber mientras era
ministro de economía y también lo último
que se supo pero que lo sacó el medio
mediapart sobre también el lobby que
hizo con la empresa amazon no como ello
también tiene y empaña digamos de esas
celebraciones del 14 de julio y también
sin entrevista no sé si lo pudo ver en
la entrevista completa le preguntaron
algo de esto el presidente manera macro
ni si es cierto que le preguntaron que
habría dicho el presidente
bueno la verdad eso es un tema desde
hace varios años cuando emanuel mccomb
era ministro de economía con una
voluntad esencial captar llamar a
invertir captar las inversiones que
extranjera y favorecer pues el empleo a
través de una atractiva y that en medio
de la competitividad internacional
entonces por supuesto ya sabemos de un
tiempo electoral daremos de con una
nueva asamblea nacional con oposiciones
fuertes y obviamente van a atacar
durante el periodo en el presidente pero
hoy en día lo importante es esa fiesta
nacional y el presidente pues no
reafirmar la voluntad de la unión
nacional
a la vez con esa atención internacional